bader ginsburg's legacy also left a mark
here locally
so many across our community are
grieving and remembering the personal
impact she had on their lives
sasha loftis spoke with some who say her
influence was especially prominent
she joins us live near the federal
courthouse near las vegas boulevard and
bonneville with more
brian we are all feeling this loss
tonight but it was especially big for
those in the legal community
i spoke with three women of color
tonight they're all
prominent attorneys here in las vegas
and they say they wouldn't be where they
are today
if it weren't for trailblazers like rbg
and as soon as i heard i just started
screaming no no no
it was really hard it was a monumental
moment
felt around the world it was universal
everyone was looking down at their
phones everyone
had tears in their eyes after 87 years
of moving some of society's sharpest
mountains
ruth bader ginsburg lost her life on
friday
she was a champion defender for women's
rights
shaping the world as an attorney
professor and most notably
her impassioned position as a u.s
supreme court justice
she's paved the way for really all women
especially in the legal community
and so to lose her and to know that so
many of us looked up to her just felt
really personal
her influence also embodied the
landscape of las vegas
unlocking countless doors and
manifesting dreams
across our legal community she has been
a role model
i think for many women
who are lawyers and who aspire to be
just as great as she's been now as we
all commemorate the tireless steps she
took
to revolutionize our reality we're
seeing the changes that she started a
long time ago
those who loved her here at home vow to
carry
rbg's legacy close to their hearts
just give thanks to her and to people
like her
now the president of the latino bar
association here in las vegas told me
that the majority of their board right
now
is women she believes that wouldn't be
possible if it wasn't for the work
of ruth bader ginsburg reporting live
sasha loftis
8 news now